14 superheroes met on the moon for a top
secret gathering fascinating three of
them turned out to be evil villains in
disguise though how many were real
superheroes real superheroes so pause
this video and see if you can figure
this out now you've had your try let's
work through work on it together
so 14 superheroes met on the moon so
let's write that down 14 met on the moon
put a little circle around it like that
so 14 men on the moon now of that 14 it
they tell us that three of them turned
out to be evil villains in disguise so
three of them are evil villains so of
the 14 we're either dealing with the
three evil villains or we're dealing
with real superheroes one way to think
about it is the 14 are made up of evil
villains or real superheroes so this
question mark right over here this is
the real superheroes this is what we
need to figure out and so this
relationship could be written in
different ways you could write you could
write that the three villains plus the
question mark real superheroes plus the
question mark real superheroes is going
to be equal to the total number of
characters that met on the moon or you
could say well if 3 plus question mark
is 14
well then 14 minus 3 minus 3 is going to
be equal to question mark is going to be
equal to question mark and you see it
right over here the 14 is made up of
three in question mark so if you get rid
of the if you take 14 minus 3 you're
just going to be left with the number of
real superheroes so what's 14 minus 3
well there's several ways you could do
this but one weighs well let's see 14
minus 1 is going to be 13 14 minus 2 is
12 14 minus 3 is 11 so we have 11 is
equal 11 is equal to question mark or
question mark is equal to 11 or there
are 11 real superheroes now let's do one
more let's do one more we found many sea
monsters in the
nearby lake nine of them have stripes
five of them have spots how many sea
monsters are in the lake how many sea
monsters are on the lake so what are
they telling us so the total how many
sea monsters like this is the total
number of sea monsters this is what
we're trying to figure out the total
number of sea monsters that's how many
sea monsters are on the lake and they
tell us they tell us that nine of them
have stripes nine nine of them have
stripes and five of them have spots five
of them have spots so all the sea
monsters are mate all the sea monsters
are going to be the nine that have
stripes plus the five that have spots so
we could write nine plus five nine plus
5 is equal to question mark is equal to
question mark and so what is nine plus
five well you might have that memorized
already that is 14 or if you don't you
could say well see nine plus one is
going to be 10 9 plus 2 is 11 9 plus 3
is 12 9 plus 4 is 13 9 plus 5 is 14 so
14 is equal to question mark or how many
sea monsters are in the lake
14